how has there not been a reunion show
cuz I I followed everybody's remarks
about a possible reunion over the years
I know some people are into it some
people are not how can there not be one
and would you be down to do it at this
point
I mean if everybody was in it or you
know and but it's a pity you know it
depends but people are in lots of
different places in their lives and I
think more than anything it would have
to be about the material I mean forget
whether or not any of us are willing to
do it I think you get something that's
that's good enough I think you know
everybody involved is smart enough to
realize when something is is is very
good I think that it's hard because that
reason geeks was about a time where
you're in between being an adult and a
child and how awkward that is and how
painful that is and how gigantic those
problems seem and then when you grow out
of them you realize that life there's
such a bigger life around just that
moment in your time in time so I think
that there's an innocence and the
fragility about that time in your life
that I think might be harder harder to
mine the same kind of comedy when when
they're older